last year's terror attacks and the
migration surge have given the drive
towards multiculturalism in Europe new
impetus this week MEP s threw their
weight behind an initiative from the
culture committee to reinvigorate the
process intercultural dialogue is about
talking to each other it is but
encountering each other learning about
each other celebrating difference
finding commonalities mass migrations
have taken place in Europe for centuries
they've led to diverse multi religious
societies the danger now warns one MEP
is for EU member states to close in on
themselves in the face of imagined
threats we all have become more or less
at least migration societies and that
means we have to deal with our own
cultural traditions but with all the
characters of the migrant societies and
communities as well you should not go
back to nationalism and to this concept
of sovereignty in their resolution M
ep's urge member states to make the most
of a raft of educational creative
research and neighborhood programs in
the EU to advance intercultural dialogue